o mega metralhadora
acho que câmara não vão no carro para o
ronaldo
e aí a festa nacional da uva você está
chovendo milsinho só atende pessoas que
quanto a quente é campo de ataque
enquanto a chuva não é quando está a
chover contacte fixo arte fica
preguiçoso abraçar pessoas e abraça a 10
segundos para descolar seu pescoço dela
fica situado a cara fica oleosa é o óleo
da camada passado os coxinha no meio da
rosneft chinela de terra e os pés que
ela tá úmida por cada chuva e até na
prega que a terra molhada esfregando já
sacou no meio da rua governo até chutar
saccol se chuta sacola praia do pego
tudo pra ninguém o quanto a quem está a
aprender enquanto a chuva está prevista
a vida gente a vida é prenhe de quase
uma fita isolante e estava de férias e
se dias e tirou uns dias pra mim que
também gratificação martelando por vídeo
vídeo vídeo vídeo vêem aí acaba que às
vezes vivem sai muito bom é conseguir um
dia de festa é seu inspirado eu fui pro
lugar para dizer para a minha volta ea
gente precisa disso a gente precisa
disso a gente precisa divulgar o
interior cheiro de chuva cheio de verde
leite natural que sai do peito da vaca a
gente adora isso ser humano corpo do ser
humano o corpo do ser humano
ama isso o trade na minha cabeça no
interior se a coisa mais gostosa do
mundo a redesim e pai conversando com a
galera e papá segundo dia a e
tranquilidade coisa linda o meu deus e
ser o dia já a nossa
e aí vaca olha como está não vai ser
fácil digitar significa que o boicote e
quando eu fui embora até o 5º dia bate
aquela saudade dói fai meu deus quem vai
falar é o meu deus é um pé de manga
destino que me five é que a dilma não
faz com a gente na casa de wifi do pé de
manga meu deus eixo de comércio da
saudade da fumaça daquele gostinho de
cinza embu 7º derrotou do ipc a minha
boca no cano de descarga de um carro
junto com a comissão nem no directshow
poluição em mim tocar na volta das
férias a volta às aulas agora existem
dois tipos de mães que deixam você e
junto quando vai comprar material e as
que vão sons mas que deixa a criança
junto na hora de comprar o material é
aquela mãe que sabe quem aguenta o filho
e cheiros a tela comprar um caderno bem
dele que me empurrou no chão
aquele menino que só consegue sair de
casa com um boneco na mão em andando bem
10 manganelli do ben 10
tudo bem meu filho mas só vai comprar um
caderno do ben 10 é você entrar nessa
não é aceita tudo na minha mãe é a
primeira vez que eu pedi um caderno do
ben 10 por ano e só então pedir um cara
do bem deve rodar bem dessa etapa na sua
boca eu disse 'não vai trazer surfista
não é mais o show eu sair com ela pra
comprar material uma vez só um ano neste
mesmo dia só se comunicavam comigo pelo
olha que vai ter a papelaria corri lá no
cada round 20 matéria para dura na cara
do zac efron high school music uma cara
do troy de high school music
oito hospitais comes to stay no caderno
acinte a sentir que não dá pra pegar
aquele eu fui com os menorzinhos matéria
epa capa dura do mickey tal sei que não
tá bom não peguei e fui para outro - em
matéria mostrar alguma trilha de
malhação que na geladeira ninguém
conhece a capa dura evitar que 13 que
oito matéria de capa mole jovens
skatistas da tilibra eu tenho que o
caderno vai pegar nenhum caderno ela é
minha amiga há uma folha escreveu
antónio mas ela pudesse lhe cortava
borracha no meio poder pagar metade do
prêmio aceitar é bom quando cantava era
bom e poderia sozinha eu ficava em casa
chorando senhor foi um menino bom esse
ano que eu bati na minha irmã dele que
eu quebrei dela mas é isso é normal
coisa de mãe não abrir ki-moon briga né
senhor quer que se olhe toda minha vida
os meus apresentava boxes todo esse
episódio falar e me diz quando foi que
te pedi alguma coisa nunca o favorito
emita um caderno bom bonito equilíbrio
não cientista não é surfista não pela
múlti deus ofício é o pior de tudo o que
sei que é um cara bonito bombado que
ninguém conhece segurando o preço como
ainda muito faz na água meu deus esse
livro não só isso também não concordo
não favor não desborde não cabem
martinho é bonitinho eu prometo
prometido nunca mais vou seguindo regras
tirar agora isso me pegou minha mãe em
casa com a sacola cavassin
é uma etapa é a primeira dor já senti
que era capa móveis em comprar viagra
pagar por cada vez a casa ficava duram
há nada aí eu estava esperando mesmo era
ver se tinha adesivo eu peguei o caderno
foi abrir mão da beleza desenho adesiva
importante na vida da criança pega
qualquer de exibição no pego grampo
grande a gente dá pra quem a gente ama o
adesivo grande só dá pra quem ritmo a
gente já pega na porta do guarda-roupa
de abril quando um robô adesivo grande a
pessoa que ela só fica [ __ ]
na compra dessas gum o meia nenê é tomar
no cu foi tudo isso eu vou chegar com a
azul negocia com azul e disse eu gostei
da quase o primeiro vídeo 2016 é gent a
4 em 6 6 milhões de inscritos eu queria
pedir que você fosse o twitter agora e
tuitar a hashtag wilson 6 milhões ha no
twitter a hashtag 16 milhões o jeito é
escrita que eu já vou deixar explicitado
no meu twitter que é isso aqui você
chega no twitter só dá rt 2006 havia
muita coisa nós vamos fazer muita coisa
bem legal aqui pra vocês vocês vão
adorar tenho certeza que é um clube que
gostei dessa formalidade incentivo que
eu vou voltar com tudo se inscreve no
canal volta lá no meu posto no meu
facebook e postou o vídeo não cheguei na
liga em curtir marca seus amigos que
também tiveram tempo de escola desse
jeito aqui muito obrigado a assistir e
até aqui mais uma vez e nós um beijão
mayhew e aguardem as novidades no parque
que falar em coisa boa em 2016